on November 25th 2022 a pilot taking off
from the Indianapolis Airport found
himself in a terrifying situation
shortly after takeoff alarms began to
ring the plane began to pitch up and
lose engine power with the full stall
imminent disaster was unavoidable but
this pilot was not flying any normal
plane he was flying a cirrus sf50 in a
last-ditch effort the pilot reached up
and pulled a red handle above his head
launching a tiny solid rocket behind the
fuselage deploying a life-saving
parachute allowing the plane and Pilots
to slowly descend to the ground this
incident is only the latest of 140
deployments which have collectively
saved over 240 people since 2002. this
tiny private jet has a unique detail
design allowing it to fly with a single
tiny jet engine ensuring the plane is
light enough for a parachute to save it
from disaster you can learn more about
the detail design by watching our insane
engineering of the f-35b documentary